welcome to the David Pakman show I am of
course not David Pakman I am Benjamin
Dixon host of the Benjamin Dixon show
and host of the upcoming show to the
point that would be hosted by are
distributed by Revere press excited to
be here with you David is out of town
he's on his way to Las Vegas for a
conference and he will be broadcasting
from Las Vegas for the remainder of the
week let's jump right into the news just
one day after Donald Trump called for
the resignation of his secretary of
Department of Homeland Security Kirsten
Nielsen it is being reported that he has
asked the Secret Service chief Randolph
Allis to step down as well now the
Secret Service is a part of the Homeland
Security and they are the administration
is saying that this is a part of a
broader shake-up to move in a different
direction with regard to homeland
security but there's a lot of things
happening underneath this firing or at
least this resignation of these Secret
Service chief the White House has
confirmed that alice is leaving that
allez is leaving however according to
CBS and the BBC the White House won't
confirm whether or not Trump is asking
him to step down or whether or not it
was an outright firing
press secretary Sarah it's Sanders Sarah
Huckabee Sanders has announced that
James Murray will be taking over in the
position and so there's a lot happening
here notwithstanding the fact that
Donald Trump has fired or has had
resigned so many positions and that we
are operating with a skeleton government
that we have people in positions who
were clearly not qualified for it not
that that's the backdrop of this story
right that Donald Trump is filling
positions with acting secretaries so
that he can circumvent the Senate
approval process all of that is in the
backdrop but there's another thing
that's happening in the backdrop that
makes this particular story extremely
concerning as well as something that
requires more investigation Chuck
Schumer so the Senate Democratic leader
has called for the outgoing chief to
testify before Congress specifically
surround
a security breach that we found out
about yesterday on Monday now yesterday
it was reported that a Chinese national
by the name of Yong Zhang was arrested
after getting access to Mara lago under
false pretenses and as they investigated
her and they searched her room they
found I believe it was nine SIM cards
I'm sorry nine USB fat flash drives
thumb drives five SIM cards multiple
debit cards and about $8,000 in cash and
they also found on this national this
Chinese national a radio frequency
device that helped detect hidden cameras
now all of that being said it's it feels
as though the timing of this is a little
too close to not take it in
consideration in terms of the firing of
course the Trump administration is
saying that them firing or having the
Secret Service chief step down is not
tied to this at whatsoever and even
Alice at least a report is coming out
that he was asked to resign ten days ago
before this news broke or before this
incident happened regardless there's so
many things that happen at mar-a-lago
that involve the Secret Service so many
different security breaches and so many
unethical things that take place at
mar-a-lago just just to pay to play
right the ability for people to pay two
hundred thousand dollars to get access
to the not just Donald Trump but to the
White House the administration national
security issues to put to be in the
environment where these types of things
are these decisions are being made
because the president spends an obscene
amount of time at his resort so there's
so many things that are going on so even
if we can't tie this firing directly to
the apprehension of this Chinese
national who by the way they they're
still investigating it's nothing
concrete we don't know the true
intentions of whether or not this was
some type of espionage we don't know
that remains to be seen but for these
two things that basically happen on the
same day the day we find out about the
Chinese national is the same day that
Trump asked or at least that it
announced that the Secret Service chief
steps down it sets off red flags and
Chuck Schumer subsequently said that the
requested that the outgoing Secret
Service chief come and testify before
the Senate so that they can ascertain
and investigate what was going on now
this again
the second backdrop that you have to
take in consideration is Donald Trump
it's really not having an administration
not having an administration that's led
by people who are confirmed by Congress
having a significant amount of
resignations almost since the very first
day having fired quite a few people I
mean we really are working with an
administration that is filled with
incompetent people and this is not
hyperbole this is not just a way of
slamming Donald Trump but quite
literally people who are unqualified for
the job number one and then Donald Trump
assigning and appointing people what by
circumventing rather the Senate approval
process and then furthermore he's
assigning people and appointing people
who are specifically and uniquely
qualified at undermining the
institution's for which they are
required to to cover and to lead so this
just shows you the type of chaos that
Donald Trump likes to operate in it may
have something to do with loyalty sure
I'm sure there's a lot of theories out
there that Donald Trump will fire anyone
who does not express a direct
hope the loyalty to him but I also think
that this is just the type of
environment that Donald Trump likes to
operate in there are some leaders who
would rather run with nothing than to
have people around them that remotely
challenge them and this again this isn't
to make it seem as though any of these
people who are working for Donald Trump
are noble people but as David covered
yesterday the firing of Kirsten Nilson
you know she did all she did just about
everything she could possibly do for
Donald Trump and once it came to a point
where she said okay well we have to obey
the law you know this is not to defend
her by any measure but Donald Trump
betrayed her because she would not put
herself in either even further damage in
in further peril by breaking the law by
half of Donald Trump so that loyalty
oath that Donald Trump requires I think
is a reasonable way of understanding why
he has no one around him but I also
think that another way of understanding
why we have such a fragmented
administration is simply because Donald
Trump loves to operate in chaos and
there are a lot of leaders who operate
in chaos because in chaos they can get
away with everything they want to get
away with today's program is sponsored
in part by Blink accom slash Pakman if
you've not already heard about blankets
it's amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
15 minute audio book you get all the
most important information and insights
from each book but you can soak up the
entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n